Do you all practice the five second rule,
raise of hands, who does
the five second rule?
be honest, yeah.
I mean, I've done like the ten second rule.
Right?
Okay.
Marthastewart.com reports that scientists
have actually tested the five second rule in a lab.
They dropped a piece of baloney.
Well, that's just like.
That's gross already.
That's like tape.
Yeah, right
No one's gonna pick something up.
It's totally tape.
And a piece of dry bread on a surface with ugh,
salmonella on it and they let it sit for five seconds,
30 seconds and then a full minute and the results are in.
Regardless of how long it sat there,
the food was very definitely contaminated.
Aw man.
Even after just five seconds,
that baloney was salmonella city.
I know.
Oh God.
Well, I mean, oh man.
I feel like there are two types of five second rules
in the world.
There's like five second rule around people
and you're like, no, I'm not gonna
and then there's the five second rule at home
where you're like, that's been there for like, I don't know,
a few minute.
I actually, one time just found a jelly bean and I ate it.
I don't know, you know what are you gonna do?
Do you remember when like Rachel and Joey are like
eating the cake in their hallway, like off the floor.
Does anyone remember that?
I do, what about Miranda on "Sex And The City",
eating the cake outta the garbage can.
She had to pour like soap on it.
I've done that.
Done it, done it, done it.
I've been like enough.
Totally.
Well.
So is this gonna skew you,
will you no longer count the five?
How often is there a patch of salmonella around?
Well, do you really wanna know the answer?
Well, yeah.
All right, up next, hey, are you ready to try
the latest TikTok trend, you guys?
Always.
Well, Allure reports
the newest makeup hack is called the tape contour.
People are using clear tape, you know,
just like scotch tape you have on your desk
as a guiding tool for applying their makeup
and we have some right here, you wanna try it?
Yes.
I'll show you how it works.
She's doing it right there.
You take a big piece of tape like this
and you just open your mouth like this.
(man muttering)
(crowd laughing)
Look at that.
Oh, you are good, good.
I feel like I got get caught on my baby hairs.
It might.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay and then.
Can you see it, can you hear it?
(crowd applauding)
And then you blend, hi, and then you're extra gorgeous, hi.
What do you think?
(crowd applauding)
I guess I could take this off now, kinda like it.
You know what I like to do is this one
where you take your, that one.
Well, look, I don't even have a line.
You're good and then I would do my eyelids too, like this.
(crowd applauding)
Pretty good.
I am freaking out, I love this, it really worked.
It does work, look at me
Before we go, if you love a good podcast, 'cause we all do
check out ours.
"The Drew Barrymore Show" podcast because we're podcasting
wherever everybody podcasts, we're there.
(upbeat music)